people who are behind black lives matter
they're a Marxist organization people
think I'm on the website of the American
Bar Association and they have all the
list of current litigation regarding the
2020 election a black guy who got killed
by the cops the black guy was a drug
addict anyway and he was resisting
arrest so it's the first there was there
was moments of Silence year like for
years after a year and then two years
after my old school for for George Floyd
on Zoom they had the whole school join
this Zoom call and they had a moment of
silence on Zoom do you remember that you
know in his we learned that in his
history the time that he robbed an
apartment and with some you know cronies
and he held a gun to the stomach of a
pregnant woman I wonder if she observed
a moment of silence for him and then
they go and take down statues of dudes
who arrived 300 years ago and then when
people vandalized George Floyd's statue
because of the stuff he did then just
then it's racist I'm not it was high on
fentanyl okay yeah I mean he shouldn't
lean on him but when you're high on
fentanyl you can die from [ __ ]
anything because you're high on a drum
right but the cop did a very terrible
thing yeah the Trump did a bad job I'm
not they I'm not American cops are out
of control I'm not even saying that
American cops are the same directions
yeah he was an [ __ ] I mean he was we
and you know that was such a sad the
saddest or most tragic part of that is
this man's death was something that we
all everybody on every side of the
spectrum agreed that this man Derek
shovin that that police officer was out
of line and he overdid it and he should
have listened to his his peers around
him and lightened up a little bit maybe
tased the guy but the fact that they
took that opportunity to unite everybody
yeah watch the whole video as a nation
were United around it and then they they
took it and just hit the ax down the
middle as many times as they could in
order to keep us divided and they
deliberately wasted that opportunity to
unite us again because united we stand
divided we fall that's where we're at
they know it so I was watching car
accident videos with my friends like a
month ago we're just sitting in the
backyard put you know something put
something on the TV it was like car
accident videos and I said I take solace
in knowing that a lot of these accidents
are from people being stupid so they're
just driving through the red light being
idiots like I take sauce and knowing
that the stuff I do negates the
probability of that happening it's the
same thing when I watch stuff like like
the like the BLM people that die you
look at it and you got to listen like
clearly to what I'm saying I'm being
trying to be very precise of how I say
it I take sauce and knowing that if you
like if you watch the whole George Floyd
video the dude was going crazy right
before he was resisting flopping out of
the car he wasn't if you just complied
and just went to the station he would
have been alive so what I'm saying is I
take sauce and knowing that if you just
did what you're supposed to do and you
just weren't an [ __ ] you would have
been fine and that's the case with like
almost all these guys you know they're
he's going to grab a knife yeah maybe he
shouldn't have gotten shot seven times
you shouldn't grab a knife while a
police officer is trying to come after
you and he's there for a domestic abuse
report trying to imply that personal
responsibility is
a factor in how our lives they don't
tell you that it's personal
responsibility they tell you that it's
the system and I agree to an extent that
police officers need more training I
know you are police officers need more
training but then they just want to get
rid of the police officers they want to
cut their training they want to cut the
funding what and then they tell people
they tell black people that they're like
the police are their enemies so if you
constantly tell them you're like they're
your enemies and all you you portray and
how are you ever gonna build you make a
relationship exactly all you make if you
know that simply complying and not being
an [ __ ] is going to save more lives
why wouldn't you tell them to just do
that why wouldn't you tell them no you
tell them that you have to be like
they're all so aggressive not all of
them not like black people are all
aggressive people that are getting into
these people that are getting into these
conflicts yeah I'm trying to be careful
with how I say stuff yeah I know you do
I mean so it doesn't matter how powerful
you are one thing anything can be
clipped up and taken out of context yeah
but I'm just saying if you you're able
to take personal responsibility for
stuff you watch these videos and you see
okay this a lot of this was in their
control if they weren't an [ __ ] they
would still be alive then you're like
all right maybe this isn't as much of a
problem in my life covid a lot of these
people are fat or like not only if
you're old you're old but if you're fat
you're way more likely to die so if you
know if you can recognize that going to
the gym getting in better shape taking
personal responsibility isn't making you
less likely to die from covid the same
thing
I think you could just like sum that up
with yes a personal responsibility for
your own actions not feeding people
reasons to hate each other teaching
people to try to build Bridges instead
of burn [ __ ] down I mean those that's
what I just got out of what you said
those things had they been implemented
years ago maybe have some real progress
these fact Checkers that were around at
the time they were only for stuff on the
left there was there was no fact
Checkers of the BLM stuff that was
clearly propaganda stuff edited when
there's the kid in Chicago that was
running from a cop and he was turning
around and got shot he had a gun in his
hand and the news outlets edited the gun
out of his hand and they cut it up so
you didn't see that yeah and I remember
seeing it at first I was like damn is
something that actually messed up did
something finally happen and it was and
then I do more research and I'm like oh
it's just more [ __ ] fact Checkers
don't check any of that stuff if you
refuted it or if you said anything
against it then the fact Checkers came
after you oh again even asked a question
even asking a question is is evil and
and racist there was another time when
when the dude stole the cops taser and
like turned around to aim the taser at
the dude and the cop shot him and then
they were like oh the cops racist I
think that's because
of skin they've convinced you you're
that naive that you think that he got
shot aiming a taser at a cop how stupid
do you have to be not even a cop if you
taser anyone with a gun you're getting
shot man what if you're purple blue
white black me I'm getting shot woman
yeah you're an idiot we acknowledged the
first thing we said was that the cop was
100 wrong and that he should have
handled it and could have handled it had
so many opportunities to handle it
better that George Floyd did not need to
die but it could have been prevented
with personal responsibility on George
Floyd's part and that is just the truth
and what are you going to do it is what
it is yeah after we're not trying to
offend it but facts and they also go the
people go off about tasers and they go
how how effective tasers are or shoot
somebody in the leg police training
doesn't teach you to shoot someone in
the leg that's there's more like vital
arteries or some [ __ ] in your leg that
you could literally bleed out from
getting shot in the leg they don't teach
you to do that and getting a taser these
dudes are wearing hoodies shooting
someone with a taser through a hoodie
isn't necessarily effective like a lot
of the time I also think it's very easy
to say you should have done this you
should have shot here you should have
shot there in the middle of screaming
and yelling in action and bullets flying
at you no okay you should have hit him
in the right toe like you know it's
really easy to Monday Morning
Quarterback on this stuff when from the
from the safety and calm of our living
rooms wonderful
home oh my God there's a big [ __ ]
crack in the first shot I'd rather
riding on the wall won't last long yeah
the feelings
[Music]